[Musik]
hallo und namaste meine lieben wir
machen heute was indisches ich liebe ja
indien die indische küche indische
bollywood filme alles und heute machen
eine mango lassi ich habe überall für
mango die muss verwertet werden und ihr
wolltet sowieso mein mann wohl dass die
rezept formiert und deshalb zeige ich
euch das jetzt und wir fangen jetzt ja
auch drücken den zutaten natürlich
brauchen wir eine mango und des weiteren
habe ich hier rosenwasser zitronensaft
dann haben wir milch das könnt ihr auch
durch wasser ersetzen und das ist ganz
wichtig joghurt hier habe ich optional
noch vanille extrakt und puderzucker und
jetzt starten wir zuerst mit der mango
und übrigens ganz danach hinweis das ist
kein original mango lassi rezept aus
indien in den machen sondern auch nelken
rein und kardamom und das ist er so für
den deutschen europäischen gaumen
gedacht und so mag das auch jeder
natürlich ist original machen dass sie
auch sehr lecker aber in sehr
gewöhnungsbedürftig und deswegen machen
wir die kitty variante
[Musik]
und das war wie für mich einfachste
methode das fruchtfleisch rauszubekommen
einfach am kern entlang schneiden und
dann direkt hier mit dem rand an eurer
schüssel eurem behälter geht auch mit
einem glas direkt rein befördern und
jetzt nehmt ihr euch euren kurier stoppt
und kuriert das ganze einmal gut durch
[Musik]
und fertig ist das mango curry das hat
jetzt keine minute gedauert also mit dem
schälen und dem pürieren wirklich keine
minute und das geht jetzt mit zum
joghurt und dann könnt ihr auch schon
mal zitronensaft dazugeben
[Musik]
es soll so mehr
konnte
jetzt habt ihr gesehen dass ich auch
schon alle anderen zutaten mit rein
gegeben habe also puderzucker zum süßen
man müsste einfach schauen ob die mango
nicht schon süß genug ist dann habe ich
habe extra ergeben dass er mich letztens
das erste mal ausprobiert weil ich
dachte mango und vanille passt
eigentlich ganz gut zusammen und das hat
auch echt gut geschmeckt und was
unverzichtbar ist das ist das
rosenwasser also ich finde das muss auf
jeden fall rein das macht noch mal so
einen schönen orientalischen
geschmackssinn indischen bollywood
geschmack ich kann es gar nicht
beschreiben aber ihr müsst das einfach
mal ausprobieren und die zitrone hilft
eben dass das ganze nicht braun wird und
das ist auch noch mal so ein bisschen
säure gibt auch noch mal schön
erfrischen
das kannst du einfach oberen und jetzt
ist es fertig und das ganze ist jetzt 24
stunden lang haltbar
am besten im kühlschrank aufbewahrt und
dann eiskalt genießen
[Musik]
wenn ihr jetzt auch lust habt auf dieses
erfrischende mango lassi dann macht es
unbedingt nach in der infobox schreibe
ich euch natürlich ganz genau die
mengenangaben und dann geht einkaufen
und macht es nach wie gesagt kalt
schmeckt am allerbesten 24 stunden ist
es haltbar und ihr könnt auch gerne auch
eiswürfel reinmachen für mich auch super
frischen für mich persönlich ist es
manchmal im sommer sogar ein frühstücks
ersatz denn ästhetik auch und falls die
frage aufkommt ihr könntet milch jetzt
auch durch wasser ersetzen
dann ist es noch kalorienärmer als es
sowieso schon ist findet euch jetzt ganz
ganz ganz viel spaß und nachmachen
natürlich freue ich mich über einen
deutschen nach oben und über einen
kommentar ein kostenloses aber sowieso
falls ihr das nicht schon längst getan
habt und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]